how's it going citizens of the reject
nation is John and Tara Erickson back
here to continue The Last of Us episode
3 on HBO and before we jump into this I
just wanted to start by saying thank you
to you for being here because when Greg
initially approached me like when the
year started I didn't think I would be
involved with any Last of Us reactions
and then Greg had the bright idea to do
this noobs thing I was already excited
enough and then he was like just hold
tight I'm gonna find the right person
for you to do this with and when he came
back and said it was you I was overjoyed
and this has been such a blast getting
to do this with you so far so thank you
for agreeing to be here and thank you
guys for being so cool and for not
spoiling everything for us it's been a
total blast so far how you feeling Tara
I'm feeling great yeah yeah you feel
yeah I got my plaid on and a red jacket
over it and I was like wow this matches
and I left the house feeling good and I
still feel good now that's good your
supply the freshest drips right at the
real rejects I gotta I gotta compliment
you but anyway guys leave a like like
for Tara's drip if you like the show
leave a comment subscribe as well
ring that
ring the bell to get notified every time
something of Interest drops here on the
real Rejects YouTube channel and if you
want to get the full experience get all
the stuff that doesn't make the reaction
highlights come sync up with your own
copy and watch along with us at
patreon.com slash the real rejects we
also got a bunch of other TV shows and
movies over there with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and
don't forget to check out Greg and
Andrew's reaction to The Last of Us for
the full on Expert gamer perspective
show them some love it's a blast I
cannot wait I've heard this episode is a
thick boy and a game changer and uh I'm
ready and I'm not ready all at once oh
my god do this thing let's freaking do
it
[Music]
what no prologue what is this show we're
not going back to the past to to crush
my soul
I mean these are great credits though
respect words do art
and look it looks like a country but it
also looks like fungus I feel like I
would hate not that on my wall but the
other stuff
yeah like I would it would be weird but
also pretty just in a weird way throw
some real fungus on your wall yes people
would walk in and go cool you know
there's so many like mushroom gummy
things advertised now to help your brain
and they all have cordyceps in them and
I'm like aren't you guys paying
attention yeah they might kill us
[Music]
foreign
that's so pretty yeah look how beautiful
that is
in nature one day I'll stop doing that
no you won't look I've been thinking
about what you're sorry I wasn't gonna
say I'm sorry nobody made you go along
with this plan you needed a truck
battery or whatever and you made a
choice so don't blame me for something
that isn't my fault oh say it girl damn
[Music]
haha Arc concluded
you know seeing as it's just the two of
us I was thinking I should
you'll get it someday you should have
stole that musket back at the Museum
girl yeah yeah yeah don't complain now
you had your chance yeah
we had supplies and Roots because we
find ourselves short on gear
which I currently am because no way
this is one character named Melina who
takes off her mask and she has monster
teeth and then she swallows you hold
them bursts out your bones
she is so cool yeah and many people
cosplay her
yeah let me take that little light on
yeah girls right on your shoulder
why why are we going down there come on
at least let him know yeah I mean like
that's a dead body you're gonna fall
onto good core strength though can she
pull herself back up though that's the
true test
oh score Tampa
to the max with 10 packs
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no oh that looks so cool yep
oh is he connected to others oh my God
do not step on him
[Music]
oh why what are you
this is my knife
there are many others like it but this
one
wowie what an effect that looks awesome
not bad
oh no okay
so that like fluffy layer of mold under
there
she's a little demented but I love her
really
picked over my ass
she got some sweet pearls yeah
if you have to get bit to be infected
then who bit the first person I bet it
was a monkey it wasn't a monkey I
thought you went to school address
School teach us how their shitty
government failed to prevent a pandemic
hey don't let them catch you saying that
I got ears everywhere cordyceps mutated
it's only got into the food supply
probably a basic ingredient like flour
sugar bread cereal pancake mix I gotta
stop eating immediately damn you
crusties we'll cut across the woods here
you should have to see I don't want you
to
yep
welcome to the Boneyard soldiers went
through the countryside evacuated the
small towns told you you were going to a
qz and you were
if there was room
if there wasn't
[Music]
oh
I killed him
usually even be
dead people can't be infected
reduce the risk
oh I said baby skull yeah oh no
wow why
not today yes
let's do this
let's get some Q Anon posts going oh
yeah
oh yes dude find this guy's place
I really like him right now but he might
be a psycho or he might just be really
prepared that's the reason to have
someone like this in your life as for
when the grid goes down right then you
have access to an Arsenal in a Panic
Room
it's got to put up with some weird
perspectives
whoa
that is Nick Offerman what
oh what is Ron Swanson doing in the
apocalypse Godspeed
damn you didn't recognize it from his
voice
no no it's funny enough I was sitting
there like thinking like my beard kind
of looks like him but he's not in this
show ah cool I'm excited
score yeah man
and I'm glad they still got all their
product placement I
[Music]
that's all I've wanted in life you know
this is the role that I want to play is
his role
[Music]
honestly I would be happy each episode
is cutting back to this dude living his
life me too never joining with the main
plot just being out here surviving off
the land
damn dude all right he knows what's
going on man
what's up
bonjour for the apocalypse yeah okay and
apparently he's also a chef this is who
the bear turns out to be eventually
I'm going to go out in the woods and
shoot that infected in the head
oh what is this little handle here
it's a trap
oh cool oh no oh that's dope
four years all right man his beard is
gonna be so big by the time we get to
the present
I'm just trying to get to Boston
for more
Baltimore qz
did it hurt
it's just just a bruise a bite bruise
Boston is that way
you can make it by Nightfall I'm really
hungry
I haven't eaten in two days doesn't
sound very long out loud does it
first my name's Frank oh yeah if I feed
you then every bum you talk to about it
is going to show up here looking for a
free lunch
and this is not an Arby's
we don't have the meats
you could use a little company buddy
close
thank you
sure
thank you this is amazing
I feel like he's now realizing maybe how
much he missed like having another
person there maybe
just with one look that's how I felt I
hope that's what it is oh or does he
think he has to kill him
maybe he's
smitten with him
gold plates came out hey oh he might be
smitten
what the [__]
everything tastes good when you're
starving yeah but not like this
Bordeaux okay Miss Vineyards oh man who
knows to pair rabbit with a Beaujolais
I know I don't seem like the type
no you do little subtext there oh please
please that was nice give me what I'm
hoping for right now yep
Bring Me Love in the Time of cordyceps
my mother
[Music]
this is you
oh my oh boy he's gonna woo him oh this
is so hard right now
oh yes baby
foreign
[Music]
that's what someone told me
because
I
have done everything I know
to try and make you
who's the girl
you're seeing about oh
there is no girl
I know
yeah yes come on yes come on just let it
happen oh
oh
[Music]
what's your name oh
wow
Love in the Time of cordyceps happened
absolutely did
and it's just gonna keep happening
nothing bad is gonna offend this tender
moment
I do
laughs
yeah
oh
you no
I'm asking for some paint and some
gasoline for the lawnmower that's all it
is you say resource management
so help me I will run through one of
your tripwires oh
foreshadowing are we hosting formal
Garden parties now no but we are going
to have friends yes
I like this guy
we will never have friends because there
are no friends to be had I've actually
been talking to a nice woman on the
radio
you want who oh
yes
oh yeah
this is the guy she was talking about
saying that they would take the girl
oh yes let's go inside Tess I want to
show you something I have been waiting
to see not inside it's like please don't
leave me with this schizophrenia guy oh
I understand
what of all the people he could have
found on the radio or actually decent
people just trying to get by
oh
you don't need you or your friend
replicating Our Lives
that offense has got a year on it tops
[Laughter]
I can get you 10 spools of high tensile
aluminum
last you the rest of your life
lives
relatively speaking you should
trade
like
songs
yes
love it
sooner or later
there will be Raiders
they'll come at night
quiet and armed
we'll be fine
yeah I got a I got a very ominous
feeling
oh
oh I traded Joel and test one of your
guns for a packet of seats
oh
[Music]
innocence I feel like this is the last
to Rob before they both die no it's not
it's only gonna get better Tara what are
you talking about yeah haven't you ever
seen a show
is it this is
oh
I'm sorry
getting older faster than you
oh
[Music]
I was never afraid before you showed up
oh
you got something to be afraid for
hold on to
they're gonna rate it night oh Jesus all
right damn it there we go no no what
if you harm one hair oh yes please get
shot in the head with a bullet whoa nice
cool what the do it do it yes
oh that's so cool
see in the bunker where the hell is Bill
[Music]
no
wow God why what a nightmare
is that bill Bill's got it covered
oh so cool
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
we gotta get
ready I'm so mad
oh my God no no no no no stop oh wow
oh bad bad bad bad bad bad also shut the
front door leave the gas on leave the
gas on defense defense will kill the
rest of the boat
I made a list for you
no oh
there's copies of all the keys I'm good
ah cool
Joel you're here you know
oh
he'll take care of you
no no no no no no
[Music]
okay oh
wow holy junk
huh
oh my gosh oh a little subversion
[__] you want you want wow
[Music]
that is a bait and switch
now paint me like one of your French
girls
Nick was supposed to be getting older
than that guy
boy I have the tables turned Frank kind
of looks like the the few images I've
seen of video game Joel
[Music]
oh
it's so sweet
great old age makeup
oh
I don't want you falling asleep in the
chair I won't you will and then your
feet get blue I'm not fighting about it
back in bed I promise you I'm gonna stay
up why because this is my last day oh no
I've made up my mind I'm not gonna give
you these every day was a wonderful gift
from God's speech I have had a lot of
bad days
but I've had more good days with you
than with anyone else just give me one
more good day
oh starting now made me some toast
[Laughter]
you'll wear when I ask we'll get married
oh
shut up
go Crush all these up
we are gonna party
I will drink it and you hit me by my
hand
bring me to our bed and I will fall
asleep in your arms
I can't
do you love me
yes
then love me the way I want you to
um
nice job with them flowers
[Music]
the hole where we first met oh
this guy he's
come on now
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
oh
oh no
For Whom the Bell Tolls will it be
enough
yeah
oh God that's so scary
oh
okay
oh what if he
I'm wondering yeah
we go together like a Romeo and Juliet
thing why are there already pills in the
bottle
oh I have to kill a horse
yeah okay this isn't the tragics
at the end of the play
oh
I'm satisfied
and you were my purpose
I do not support this
oh it should be furious but from an
objective point of view
it's incredibly romantic it is yeah
[Music]
I hope they left 80s playing
okay
oh Christ Church
[Music]
foreign
to whomever but probably Joel
please do not come into the bedroom we
left the window open so the house
wouldn't smell I'm guessing you found
this Joel because anyone else would have
been electrocuted or blown up by one of
my traps
[Laughter]
and I respect you
so I'm gonna tell you something because
you're probably the only person who will
understand
I used to hate the world and I was happy
when everyone died oh my God I was wrong
because there was one person worth
saving
I leave you all of my weapons and
equipment used them to keep
oh no
Tess safe
oh
yeah process that
Tesla truck was it the tractor Oh I
thought it was a truck
he's gotta have some car batteries
he's got to rule one you don't bring up
tests ever
you tell anyone about your
condition you do what I say when I say
it we clear
this is joltatorship let me grab what we
can
it's gonna be too much just live here
yeah
dude no
[Music]
I should take some of them at least yeah
all of them load them in that
oh the gun the little one uh
please just know how to use it I'm in
handy yeah okay it's your first time in
a car it's like a spaceship
the Chevy S10 but it'll get us there
good piece of [__] serious spaceship
please tell me they loaded all the guns
in the trunk they put one pistol back
there
just to Rattle around better be the
whole dang shebang
yeah of course
official music of the Apocalypse
oh
[Music]
damn I hope we go back there someday we
probably won't but I hope we will
we must ah of course
[Music]
Focus rack
well done
yeah just cut to their dead bodies
really quick I thought it was gonna Zoom
all the way up to them like on the bed
holding hands oh yeah that your your
version's better than mine
oh man that was an emotional roller
coaster yeah I'm exhausted I mean I I
yeah like I was like oh God don't start
scream sobbing you gotta like I mean I
can cry but like tuck it in a little bit
Yeah I was close to like [__] those
tears yeah
next time you should you should cry I'll
let it out okay as you can all right
dude I can do that I'll do it I'll make
it happen
wow all right
let's talk about it yeah we got [__] to
talk about Terror Ericsson huh we really
we really do except I'm also just just
hearing my feels I think I need a second
to put my heart back together yeah like
so the pieces back together
all right oh
what a fun episode right
it's so fun that was just like the
bounciest I mean when they said this
episode was going to be a comedy I was
like I don't think you guys could pull
this off no you know laughed the whole
way through almost as funny as Chernobyl
I don't know if you know how funny
Chernobyl was
hilarious no that was that was a really
beautiful episode I I I was not at all
expecting where that went and again as
we progress in this experience I am more
and more engrossed and fascinated by
what
the what the correspondence is between
the show and the game because I don't I
don't go out of my way to read you know
every inch of side by side how is this
in the game like is this like a huge
plot Point like before you go to a Next
Level they tell this a huge like
beautiful story that's like Romeo and
Juliet I'm like there's an hour-long cut
scene of just this yeah like okay good
point I did I wasn't even my brain was
not there in like video game land uh
sorry to interrupt you of like oh yeah I
forgot this is also a video game and an
adaptation and I'm like how does this
play into it but yes you do cut to you
just like become Bill at one point and
you just like walk around and kind of
aim at stuff but don't shoot yeah and
then you fall in love
press press X to follow along all right
and to spend your life with the the man
of your dreams but yeah I really like
the way this episode wove in and out of
time of points in time and the way it
Incorporated Joel and Ellie because so
so much of this is about Bill and Frank
and yet I thought they proportioned and
paced it really nicely and and part of
me you know uh when you really start to
get into the meat of Bill's story I was
like okay are we just this is just gonna
be I was sort of settled into the idea
that it's just gonna be them for the
rest of the episode and I was cool with
that and I I thought it was a really
neat surprise the way they Incorporated
Joel and Tess in flashback yeah sort of
you're you're yeah you're in the
progression of this timeline in
isolation but also flashback in the
greater timeline and then you re-join
the present with them findings sort of
yeah the conclusion of this you know
unlikely apocalypse love story and uh
and yeah I just thought the way they
drew these characters again was really
nicely done and I think that yeah having
I I think Nick Offerman is a
particularly good casting decision
because you see him and you know you
have this you have this immediate
Association of I'm making my own I'm
living off the land self-sufficient so
good I'm gonna I'm gonna fall in love
but I'm gonna kill my own meat and eat
it too uh I gotta I gotta my Nick
Offerman gets better the more I hear him
and he didn't talk a tons
I feel like Nick was right here in the
room with me that's the greatest
compliment I could ever hope to receive
terrorism but yeah like you have his
casting and you you see him you realize
him and you're like okay like I can
already see him playing this kind of guy
and yet I think they use that sort of
against you because he's got this
reputation for playing characters and in
life kind of being a character that's a
very man's man you know uh you know or
uh man of the land kind of thing
renaissance man in a lot of ways and and
yeah this plays on that but then twists
on it too and I think that was really
nice how tender and intimate they
allowed that story to be and the way
that you have you you meet him and we
are all projecting on to him and we're
like ah this this doomsday prepper
probably q a non-conspiracy guys
probably got every Prejudice you could
imagine and yet it's it's not really
about that and it is kind of fascinating
to see
you know like a new life born out of the
collapse of most other life yeah is it
interesting yeah it was just an
interesting way to do that but what what
what are your thoughts I mean he likes
review for myself he would be like the
least uh reasonable person that you
would ever think would fall in love
during the apocalypse he's like the 180
degree turn of like oh no not him
somebody else and I like that they play
with that and that he did and you get to
see oh really like you said intimate
side of their relationship
um
and also there was one thought where I'm
like they still have meat for all these
years but like do the animals not get
cordyceps too are they not in fact
they're not oh no they're not because we
went in the water sorry I that was a
hard left turn I have eight it's okay
um the animals in the water from the
episode before anyway
um that was on my brain a lot so I
thought I needed to clear that up
um
I yeah I uh I don't know I I really I
love the story I didn't didn't see that
coming and I feel like there's a huge
metaphor in there in regards to what he
wrote to Joel saying that that's what
we're meant to do we're meant to I love
this person I I protected him and that's
what we're meant to do and although he
wrote four tests it's obviously now for
her to like protect her and get her to
the same spot even though
he did he does not want the task of
Ellie but he has it now but I feel like
he has a better guide and the resources
because of they're good old friends yeah
and it feels like even though at the end
of the episode he's like no personal
[__] we're not talking about any of that
yeah I feel like we are sort of watching
you know the walls slowly being chipped
away at starting with Linda Ronstadt she
can chip those walls down she starts
singing and you're like where are you
from and everyone's like I am uh let me
tell you my life story now yeah
oh man that whole thing of the piano and
like really great use of of a music you
know what comes back as a needle drop
but is such a great little intimate
moment there yeah I don't know I I
really loved you know you come into a
show like this and I think what's on
your mind is like Carnage and and
creatures and harrowing acts of just
scraping by and when zelly gonna finally
fire a gun but yeah I I really like the
way that they let you live in this
scenario and the way that yeah in a way
even though we've spent so much of these
first two episodes being like look how
much everything has gone to [__] and
look how horrible life is now and you
look at the quarantine Zone and you're
like yeah this isn't
the ideal kind of life this is sort of a
rough life even if there is safety in
numbers and resources and and whatnot
and then you cut over here and and I
guess they must just have some kind of
generator or he must have stocked up on
enough fuel to you know keep their
utilities running but that aside yeah
it's like they they manage in the worst
circumstances to thrive to yeah to live
so many years like 20 years yeah yeah
and they and they you know they have a
lovely house uh you know Frank paints
and Bill Cook's like culinary you know
like yeah he's making like real dishes
and stuff like that and yeah it's like
you get the I love that they show you
both like they had
I love the way they play with tension
because I was tense for other reasons
throughout this I was like oh God is
their relationship gonna fall apart for
just like human Petty reasons or
differences in their sensibility and
yeah those things you know are touched
upon and he says that whole thing about
like I had some bad days with you but I
had way more good days and and yeah like
the humanity with which they drew all
that and the way again that they give
you enough to project on especially with
Bill but not too much like I think it is
an interesting
thing to explore because you know this
is the kind of person who does existent
now and would probably Thrive once the
grid goes down yeah it was weird I mean
you want to be friends with that person
but not with the world with living
people in it you want to be friends with
that person when you like it's your last
resort I mean because I feel like he
hated people right so it's funny we need
people like that but you I mean you'd
have to get in good with him yeah before
before the world that's right find your
otherwise doomsday prepper and and yeah
slip them get in good now because if you
try to do it later bullet in the head
that's right it's not going to work out
for you be remembered it's like Oh no
you're the one who brought me canned
goods every once in a while you're cool
come down into the bunker with me I'm
gonna I'm gonna I you know what I would
do I would like start saving candy I'd
be like people are gonna be bringing you
canned goods and I've got Sour Patch
it's fun for you I got some good the
good juice I got a taste of Youth for
you
yeah this was like this this is one of
those things where it's got all the cool
genre stuff you want but this also looks
like a real gift for like an actor to be
able to come in and to you know get a
role on a show like this and I mean even
even Tess who has been the most
short-lived character of prominence so
far like even seeing her back for a
moment and getting this hint at the what
seems to be the
unrealized you know connection they
could have had something that seems like
Joel is probably holding in an arm's
distance because of his unresolved
traumas of the past
um yeah I don't know I'm curious to see
if and how like if this is the last time
we see her on screen or not
right it was also very similar that like
Tess and Frank are like the same and so
when they both leave the table it's very
much like a mirror looking into a mirror
right with like Joel and Bill it's sort
of like you think you're maybe very
different but you're very much the same
which also comes up when Bill writes him
that letter that it will probably be
Joel showing up too to read this and
yeah
yeah this is so much personality like
like I think they did a really nice job
of of getting you like I cried in this
episode they got you to that point where
you care and you have the feels and yet
they still have a bit of levity and
they're really good like this episode I
think is is an example of them being
really good at being they're good at I
swear I'll get this sentence out I
promise you they're good at playing the
situation against you because so much of
this I was tense for like a bunch of
reasons because you're just like when's
the shoe gonna drop and the shoe just
isn't the shoe you're expecting and even
when the Raiders show up which is like a
cool sequence but I appreciate that they
didn't even need to indulge in it like
they're they're so good at locking you
into perspective and using that to get
you invested and to get your heart rate
up and and yeah like we didn't have to
dive too far into it like where they
like show them all and like it's a huge
fight where it's like you really just
see it true POV of Frank indoors really
looking during all those explosions
which I'm like that's so cool the way he
set it up the house but like the point
of view I think is like is awesome in
that regard yeah and you know Bill is
capable and yet it's not like okay he's
gonna take out 12 guys before they get
him inside like you know it is like yeah
traps the prep did most of the work
that's what it's there for and then that
I thought like the way they transitioned
then to the next phase of their life and
you're like oh bill must be in the
wheelchair because of where he got shot
no actually uh Frank just has
uh what I assume is just some real life
degenerative disease of some sort that
is you know affecting his mobility and
all that stuff and and then yeah
watching them
choose where
yeah in in this version of the world
more than any other if you're faced with
a situation where yeah you have to
you know live with just the wear and
tear of Being Human yeah I guess you
would want to choose your terms that
makes it that makes you unlike you would
be so hard yeah which is what you know
he was facing which I'm like oh man
that's so it's so that's so tough I
would yeah that's just hard because you
can't you're just not you anymore yeah
exactly and it's and I loved the way
they handled that conclusion because
yeah you see how hard it is for for Bill
to know this is going to be Frank's last
day
and even though I think we're all
sitting there going
Bill's going to join him like still the
way they handled that in the way that
they you know they don't reveal it they
let it really unfold naturally and
compassionately was just yeah I guess he
took time there was like a breath of
they they said it and then they really
did show it and took their time showing
of like that that was what the day was
gonna be and they just slowly kind of
went through it and I did not feel like
bored at any point of like we already
talked about it so why it was just
really beautifully done and then the
soundtrack is also obviously amazing
they do yeah it's they do it in that way
where you're with Bill in the sense of
like I don't I don't want this day to be
over like let's see yeah let's let's
watch you guys go to the boutique let's
watch you guys do your little your
marriage ceremony let's let's spend some
more time at dinner before this is all
over and done with yeah and yeah it is
like
it's tragic but also really really
beautiful in a way that I think I'm
going to be kind of thinking about and
processing you know between now and when
the next episode lands because this is
just so far removed from again so much
of what is just omnipresent in the
situation like as much as the the
apocalypse escape and the circumstances
that we live in are everywhere it's like
kind of the last thing on your mind in
this episode you keep thinking it's
going to burst through and yet it
doesn't really yeah yeah it definitely
doesn't which is uh well except for one
sheet cut open the guy's forehead and it
was look like a nice fluffy pillow that
you could just wrap yourself in
acceptance
gnarly and you don't it's molds yeah oh
yeah I guess it's mold but mold looks it
looks comfy it does you know having that
under having that layer of plush
underneath your skin it's just like a
premium pillow you know the premium
stuff inside I don't know what the
premium stuff is people are gonna start
injecting that into their faces pretty
soon
would it make it fluffier in certain
places because maybe maybe I would get
into it and get a molded injection for
fluffiness yeah you could fluff your
face and then if it was like if it was
like a good mold that mold can fight off
other like the bad mold maybe yeah like
you know mold against mold except I put
in the good mold and it gets rid of the
other mold good molds you know I just
want that to be somebody's slogan
someday it'll happen black mold it's a
good mold yeah we can figure it out sure
sure yeah
well all right man this was a very
effecting very touching episode yeah we
only we only saw one iceberg lettuce
head and it wasn't even a full one he
just like Had a Little Flower there that
was awesome that was such a cool
practical effect like with the bricks on
that guy I loved every part of that was
super cool and I like that they put
Ellie in that position of we all know
that she's cool and capable and a little
bit of a badass but it right then she
got so close and then just was like let
me just see what's here all right let's
kill it I really like that there was
just no
um hesitation for her yeah which made me
enjoy her even more it was almost like a
Fascination it's like she's yeah which I
was like she's a little demented but in
a cool way yeah I think they're good at
really portraying her as somebody who
feels like they grew up in this
environment so yeah it's like when she
realizes the infected guys down there
there is that moment of like okay I
gotta have my wits about me but also you
know you're not going anywhere so I
guess I am just going to kind of respond
with Fascination and see you know I'm
gonna poke at you a little bit before I
you know do what needs to be done and
get back yeah I feel like in every other
classic like TV show they would have
been like oh girl now yells for Joel oh
I hate and I'm just so glad that did not
happen and she just kept to herself
didn't even share when she got out she
was just like yeah yeah getting rifle
through anything which I it fits her
character but sometimes you never know
yeah it's just an interesting
illustration about her not some way to
contrive a momentary like
yeah oh it was really nothing though it
was fine you know right yeah you can
take care of herself just like she's
like a little Tess yeah yeah I mean for
sure and in a lot of ways probably
better off for this universe uh and yeah
this this really also makes you just
appreciate the little things like every
time someone takes a shower you're like
that looks like the best shower yeah
just like seeing them cleaned up
afterwards you're like I feel 50 cleaner
now
and uh and seeing like you know
beautifully cooked food and stuff like
that like it's it speaks to the
transport of nature of of this as they
you know I mean
their details enough but I think they do
nicely to capture and to live in these
things or with the strawberries stuff
like that where yeah it's like they are
overcome and from here now you're like
hey you know yeah I get it fine they're
strawberries but I don't know yeah
they're good at accentuating all that
stuff and I like that they put as much
TLC into that as they do into all the
other you know facets of the show and
yeah in this in this environment it does
sort of feel like especially a place
where if your life isn't livable in a
sort of Humane sense anymore like yeah
you would just have your own terms
to wrap up on so to speak and uh and
yeah I really love the way that they
brought that together because it hits
and it hurts but it's beautiful and then
you get to the present moment
and you know it's not even like there's
a huge like they discover what happens
but I think a different show would have
been like door opens there's them in the
bed right and yeah it's not even about
that and uh and yeah you I love that
last shot where you just come in through
the window
and there's yeah there's there's so much
life even though there's so much lack
and loss of life at the same time uh
yeah I thought this was beautiful and
beautifully told beautifully handled and
uh props to to both Nick Offerman and
and whoever the actor is who played
Frank because uh like their chemistry
and their vulnerability together and uh
so good yeah just like a really
beautifully told relationship of you
know
characters We're not gonna see anymore
but who yeah feel now like a fully
ingrained part of this expanding story
yeah it's like Bill and Frank gave there
what they had left like there they live
on in regards to what they have brought
Joel and Ellie yeah which I enjoy which
is plays with that shot of them driving
off but it's through the lens of their
window where they chose to say goodbye
and uh you see just not new life but
more life just taking on yeah carrying
on and the way that you know their
connection because they found each other
and because Bill made that choice to to
you know hear this guy out and to you
know maybe you know extend him a few
just those little brief uh uh you know
Charities that he gives him these little
considerations then Blossom out into
something that yeah helps and and feels
hopeful in a strange sort of way and it
feels like yeah even though they're not
here anymore more there's at least this
little Haven and I don't know if we'll
ever come back here but it feels like
you know it this has persisted for 20
odd years and even though their you know
journey is complete you know they're
still helping the good fight
yeah even though this guy wouldn't be
the type to want to fight for people you
know I hope that Joel and Ellie they
find friends wherever they go and they
end up back there yeah and and sort of
reliving out what Frank said we will
find friends and we'll invite them over
to Love and Hope are the true fungus of
humanity that's true they grow and they
spread and uh and yes sometimes you
can't stop it even if you want to no
even if you're like I don't want love
level that I hate people but look at you
helping people look at you being good
people hopefully
you know I mean you don't have to be
confronted with who bill was before
everything went to [__] you don't have
to think about like
just got like a super racist or
something like that right they really
confront you with that but but yeah I
don't know I thought this was a really
neat uh experiment and a cool way to
humanize character at least bill is the
kind of character who I feel like people
would they they they're counting I think
on you having a knee-jerk reaction and
then they humanize from there and I
think that was yeah beautiful yeah so
well any stray thoughts before we skip
dads ah maybe have some tissues on hand
for the rest of these episodes because
you never know yeah I mean that was like
a turn I didn't know I didn't know it
was coming tonight
you know
just lots of Tears so tissues that's all
that's my that's my one note which has
nothing to do with the show and
everything to do with John because John
he should have just had you should just
have everything provided here for me
tissues in case I clean Yeah clean cry
tissues in case I need to clean the
workstation
wow did I have a stroke and not know it
I hope not tissues in case I Cry
water there's no there's no water not
here not here today okay I have coffee
but there's water in coffee I might need
water okay and
um I would love some feet warmers
because it's cold in this house and
that's all I have to say
we'll we'll drive to the to the General
Store the General Store eat warmers I
left a stash under a floorboard and uh
yeah all the feet warmers and tissues
and stuff they're all in there and a big
old jug of water for you he's gonna feed
me to the cordycep guy that's right
because I requested water and red
warmers and tissues clean up in here I'm
not hearing the apocalypse to make
friends Tara
that'd be good this this universe needs
a reality show yeah it's like naked and
afraid but you're just out in a field
with a bunch of cordyceps infected
cordyceps people
thank you
well all right people leave us your
thoughts leave a like on the video that
always helps out and uh and stay
non-spoilery again appreciate you guys
being so accommodating of us noobs thank
you and not uberponing us in the
comments yeah and uh last but not least
Tara Erickson yes let's shout out a
patron let's do a patron of the day
shout out
I just wanted to say I hope you're doing
all right I know times have not been the
easiest but it was your birthday just
recently and uh we want to celebrate you
a little bit yeah you have a happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy birthday
happy birthday to you you adeptly
avoided the copyright claim that could
have come in from singing happy birthday
to Mark Leach yeah and it's still a
copyrighted song and they still have to
credit it in movies people stuff to pay
for that Mark really that's what we're
willing to do the shout out is the word
of Thirteen thousand dollars wow or
however much it costs to place that uh
but yeah buddy I hope you're doing well
I hope 2023 is looking up and I I just
hope you're feeling loved and supported
and uh you know I mean we appreciate the
support you bring us month after month
and uh yeah so just uh send in some good
will your way and no matter what happens
we love you here at the reject Nation so
be well buddy and uh we'll catch you
next month cheers
[Music]